all right time now for a new Hannity
watch segment and that is the vetting of
the 2020 radical Democratic candidates
like we have been telling you a new
radical wing is now taken over the
Democratic Party pushing an agenda of
open borders higher taxes more
government control of your life and
today California senator Kamala Harris
became the latest to enter that 2020
race and while our campaign kickoff
focused on so-called unity and justice
bumper stickers platitudes her comments
as a sitting senator have been some of
the most despicable in Washington like
when she compared brave Border Patrol
and ice people to the KKK take a look
the Klan was a what we would call today
a domestic terrorist group why why why
would we call them domestic terrorist
group because they tried to use fear and
force to change political environment
are you aware of the perception of many
about how the the the power and the
discretion and ice is being used to
enforce the laws and do you see any
parallels if you had to be stuck in an
elevator with either president Trump
Mike Pence or Jeff Sessions who would it
be
does one of us have to come out alive it
gets far worse remember when she got
busted for releasing deceptively edited
video to smear justice Cavanaugh and
push the anti-catholic bigotry by
grilling one of president Trump's
judicial nominees over belonging to the
Knights of Columbus how is this in any
way unified how is this good for the
country and its not just criticism from
the right
Harris is even facing opposition for not
being progressive enough senator Harris
isn't the only troubling Democratic
candidate New York senator Kirsten
Gillibrand literally staking out her
socialist agenda to try and win loyalty
from the base of the far left Democratic
Party now Gillibrand appears to be
learning from her mentor Hillary Clinton
about the power of flipping and flopping
to try and win votes for example this
week she told the New York Daily News
she now favors giving illegal immigrants
driver's licenses after coming out
against that
2007 and during an interview on ABC on
Sunday she was pressed about her stark
shift on immigration but offered few
specifics for the change now like I've
been saying this is all going to get
much crazier we're going to give you a
front row seat it will be entertain